and we are live welcome everybody to
another YouTube hangout really excited
to be on with you again today I have a
special guest Amy Applebaum is the
creator of podcast called pitch me moms
and she's gonna come on and she wanted
to interview me for her podcast and I
thought that's cool but why don't we do
it as a youtube interview as well so you
guys could benefit and you could also
learn about her the websites
Amy Applebaum calm have linked it up in
the description below so Amy is going to
take over the show which is gonna
introduce herself and then like run a
podcast like she normally would and then
we're gonna answer questions at the end
so Amy welcome may be quick intro for my
audience and then I then run it like
it's your show thank you oh my gosh I'm
so excited
I love Evan Carmichael I love me some
Evan Carmichael so thank you so much for
coordinating this like this it's gonna
be awesome
gosh what should your audience know
about me I've been a business coach for
18 years which seems crazy I'm 46 I have
a three year old which makes me even
more crazy all right my goal in life is
that people actually love their business
and don't have to struggle through it
and the way that we don't struggle
through it and the way that we succeed
is to keep on moving mostly we end up
not succeeding because we quit and
that's something that we don't want to
have happen so welcome to pitch me moms
I'm so glad that you're here I'm Amy as
you know I'm a successful mom preneur
I've built three businesses I'm the mom
of a badass three year old and I'm a
master at vetting out put your business
ideas and today we're going to talk
about overcoming fear most specifically
how to go from panic to profit in your
business and I'm just so excited because
we get to be hanging out with Evan
Carmichael who for me is entrepreneur
extraordinaire somebody who has very
recently helped me move past a fear and
I'd really like to start by sharing that
story Evan shower let's do it um it's
kind of an embarrassing story because
most people wouldn't think that the
YouTube channel or launching a YouTube
channel would scare me and I had this
wonderful excuse three years ago
um I was pregnant and getting ready to
give birth and I was supposed to start
my youtube channel but I just I had this
reason that I used to put it off this
excuse but the reality is when I
couldn't put it off any longer which was
about eight weeks ago um I got really
present with what was really there for
me and I've spoken it I think my largest
audience was ten thousand people you
know this is like what I do but there is
something really intimate about a
YouTube channel
that really frightened me and I think my
biggest fear was not being liked making
a fool out of myself
doing videos that you know we're kind of
a mess in the beginning because I didn't
really know what I was doing and I
didn't know how to use the mic and the
earphones and handle the lighting and
and it's like you're and you're so
vulnerable
we're right here talking to each other
and I could really blow it and not get
it perfect and it just tapped into that
thing that I know about perfectionism
that's been a journey for me in trying
not to achieve perfectionism because it
doesn't exist and I had this really
great conversation with Evan he took the
time to really just put it out there and
say first of all you're gonna have to
get over that and just get it out there
and you're gonna make it better as you
go which duh I know this but clearly
needed a dose of this medication I mean
seriously I think that as long as you're
stepping outside of your comfort zone
you are never gonna be void of fear fear
when you when you're stepping out of
your comfort zone when you're doing
things that you haven't done before fear
is present it's there and it was there
for me and you really just kind of
talked me through the mechanics of
you've just got to do it you know and
you're gonna do this and you're gonna
mess up and whatever just keep going and
he was so supportive incredibly
supportive said please come on my show
as soon as you feel good about it
and I'm really happy to say Evan you're
not gonna believe this but I've shot 200
videos in an 8 week period Wow nice 200
freaking videos
and I am Not Afraid of YouTube videos
anymore I just am like whatever put it
out there some people who like it some
people won't and that was the other
thing that I really got a lot of value
from with our conversation was you know
there's gonna be your there's your posse
and there's not your posse and that's
just the way of the world
if people you know some people are gonna
love you some people aren't gonna like
you and that's okay because we're out
there trying to make a difference with
the people who want us to make a
difference for them and that's what we
need to focus on so Evan thank you for
that no problem you took the the action
that's so that's what I love that's
great
thank you yeah I did it was a lot of
work let me say that but it's fun and I
can whip them out now and I feel
confident and you were a really big part
of that so thank you so much and so I
like to introduce you to my community a
lot of them already know you I'm proud
to say that you're one of my mentors he
is an entrepreneurial expert at 19 he at
19 he built and sold a biotech software
company so you got to get you a piece of
heaven because he's really summer he was
a VC helping raise 500k up to 15 million
K he now runs Evan mark R Michael calm
Evan Carmichael CA are mi CH AE L calm
please check him out it's a popular
website for entrepreneurs and he just
lives breathes and bleeds this stuff he
is totally dedicated to helping a
billion entrepreneurs which I have to
ask him about that because that's a lot
he wants to help them change the world
and then some really cool facts about
him he set two World Records but you're
gonna have to tell us about that Evan he
uses a stand-up desk which is really
good for your back he rides a Vespa so
he's kind of cool he raises funds for
Kiva even cooler he speaks globally he
lives in Toronto super cool and he loves
his wife and his son and deejaying and
salsa dancing and Evan so excited that
my audience gets to know you I'm excited
for this let's do it right so I have all
sorts of questions for you and
I'm not even sure where I want to start
like what do you mean you sold a biotech
company at 19 I before we get into the
fear piece of this what can you give us
the can you give us the short version
yes and fear was a big part of that so I
had a company I was 19 I was I was one
of three owners I always thought I
wanted to be a banker you look at my
high school yearbooks is what do you
want to be in 10 years and I said VP at
a bank that was my career path and that
I to friends University started this
company and they asked me to join I
don't know anything well science there's
my worst subject that dropped as soon as
I could
I'm not a programmer could not code but
I joined on the business side when my
two partners were doing the actual
coding and we sucked at the start just
sucked like I was a hundred dollars a
month not surviving
I turned down what I thought would be my
dream job
you know Merrill Lynch offered me a job
in McKinsey Consulting offered me
opportunities and like fly me to New
York and put me up in the Waldorf
Astoria and you know figure starting
salary and travel in the world it's like
this is great this is what I always
thought I wanted and here's this tiny
little company that was struggling and
and I just had to go for that instead of
doing the job I thought I always wanted
and that took overcoming a lot of fear
and it was not it's easy to talk about
in hindsight but that was maybe the most
scared I've ever been in my life doing
that yeah and what was so scary about it
because here's a huge thing I thought I
always wanted here's the safe path
here's the thing that everybody you know
around me is telling me is a good thing
to do what my friends all wanted the
safe secure job that again I thought I
always wanted and to trade it off for a
company that was not doing well where I
wasn't making any money like that that
that was hard that was hard to turn down
that dream opportunity to do my own
thing and I never did you why did you do
it
like really cuz that that's like yeah
that is a dangling carrot that you did
not take the thing that made me bust
through was was regret like I did not
want to live with regret and regret
helps you bust fear you know I look at
myself at 90 years old the heart roll
I'm gonna be when I'm on my deathbed
looking back and I did not want to
regret not taking that opportunity and I
thought the thing that made it easy for
me was I thought you know what some of
my friends are taking a year off and
like traveling the world and trying to
find themselves or whatever I'm gonna
take a year to do this business thing I
could always come back and I may not get
that Merrill Lynch job but they'll be
another job they are like to take I'm
gonna take the year and try to do my own
business and no was I always courageous
like that I think I you know believe is
what I'm all about my parents want me to
believe in myself my my sister's always
did super well at school and every year
I had to have the sit down with my
parents to talk about why I wasn't doing
well in school and that B's and C's all
the time instead of AIDS like my sisters
but to their credit it wasn't it wasn't
like comparing me to them and it wasn't
telling me that I need to do better it
was always from a good place and that
they would tell me I'm like astrally
Carmichael my mom's last name is Chris
truly in that I could do anything and
that was always the message and it was
always making me feel like you know that
I could do anything that I applied
myself to and so yeah that's pretty um
that's pretty incredible it really says
a lot about how much mindset sets you up
for success or doesn't set you up for
success and you had this incredible
opportunity to be black I'm een just an
incredible blessing to have parents who
put that into your brain really young
like believe believe believe I mean this
is your life so now when I'm looking at
your Evan Carmichael beliefs I and I'm
realizing this is more than just this
has been this is your life this is this
is where you came from what do you say
there's so many people out there who
don't come from that and so they don't
have that routine pattern of hearing
that number one but thinking it
believing it and then living out of it
you say to them I think it starts with
accepting responsibility for your life I
think it starts with stop blaming your
parents and stop blaming your friends
and stop blaming your government and
stop blaming whatever like look at
yourself in the mirror and ask yourself
why you're not successful and and the
end result is going to be it's on you
like you can spend the rest of your life
hating your parents for not being there
or raising you wrong or not coming from
a family of wealth or bla bla bla like
all these reasons where once you start
accepting responsibility for your life
like the cavalry is not coming this is
on you to turn these things around then
then that's when you can start making
changes like that's the first mindset
shift to make is that I am responsible
for everything that happens in my life
and I'm not going to blame anybody else
it doesn't matter if Trump is President
or Clinton as president or whoever
like I'm making my life and until people
fully embody that then they're not going
to make a change like that there are
there are solutions but until you fully
embody that like none of the solutions
just over you yes I love it you're
driving your bus you're in charge of
your own vehicle you're it you're
driving as long as you choose that
you're driving then you can actually do
something about your life but but you
know what I'm hearing and believes so
strongly and myself is as soon as you've
given up the controls and you say
someone else is driving then someone
else is driving and you really just you
have no choices about how you want your
life to look be it the success that you
want and how you want to be day-to-day I
love that you know you were talking
about your fear was there a moment like
what was your darkest hour like I know
you were afraid of the situation but was
there a moment that you had that was
like holy [ __ ]
you know what I mean the the worst day
of my life was actually in running my
business it wasn't in and making that
decision to jump into the business it
was when I just felt so worthless
because up until that point
you think that I applied myself to I I
could I would get better at you know
like if I worked harder at sports I
would become a better athlete if I you
know worked on my free-throw I'd get
more of them in if I practice more my
piano classes I'd get better here I was
being an entrepreneur and just sucking
hard like and I was putting in I was
putting in the work I was put in the
work being lazy and exactly if you're
lazy then you know right but I was
working I was busting right and in you
know I think you can only take it for so
long you know again making 300 hours a
month I'm eating beans for lunch every
day
we wouldn't celebrate by going to
McDonald's and getting french fries and
we got a big win not not not a not a
meal just french fries because that's
all we could afford
and I had to say no to all my friends
who wanted to go out for beer or
birthdays or whatever I had to pick one
thing a month that I could go to because
that's all I could afford
like 20 bucks might not be a big deal
that's a big deal to me when you're
making 300 and and I was too afraid and
too ashamed to tell them like here I was
turning down the big job do my own thing
like I'm the guy they look up to respect
and I was too embarrassed to say guys
like I am just massively struggling so
one day I was at a family event in and
you know my partner and I disagreed on
where we're gonna take the company you
know when you're when you when you're
broke right where are we going to take
our $300 a month company no craftsman is
straws right like we had a we had a we
had a the same vision but like how we
execute it like you're try something
doesn't work you're trying something
doesn't work it just gets insanely
frustrating and we had a phone call was
I don't know if it's Thanksgiving or
some kind of family event and I was at
my mom's house and I just hold my quit
like you know what I'm quit I can't do
this I feel so worthless I need the
burger I can't just have the fries yeah
like I got to do something meaningful
with my life like this is nuts this is
not working and I hung up the phone and
and just hearing me say that I quit on
something like
here about was just nonsensical like it
just I just I'm sorry your mother would
not have been that would not have been a
proud moment for your mother right yeah
I'm crying
you know stuff is coming out of my nose
is just like right yeah my mom hears me
comes up puts her hand on my shoulder
and I don't remember what she told me
you know but just tried to soothe me I
went to sleep in you know barely slept
that night and that was just like the
worst day of my life ever and then I
woke up the next day and and I thought
you know what I like I can't quit it's
like there's something crazy about being
entrepreneur like you have to be crazy
you have to be a little bit something
wrong you got to be a little crazy yeah
I know what to I think I got it you know
we got to find a different way to do it
like what we're doing is not working I
got to find a different way to do it and
I showed up at my partners we worked out
of his apartment like we didn't have an
office his apartment was the office
dining table dining room table the
kitchen was too small there was no
kitchen table it's a condo it was your
fold-out not even though I wish luxury
and to his credit he didn't like he
could have been a real pain in the butt
like he could have questioned me you
could have you know say well I thought
you you got to give me a hard time you
just open the door like you had a moment
we're back right back to work now I had
to know like I had to find a different
way to stand and how I came out of that
is its own story but yeah but that was
that was yeah that was the worst day of
my life it's so 90 I don't know if you
read this in Forbes last month 90% of
all businesses fail I think that's high
I don't always believe the statistics
that sounds like insane however I don't
think that's accurate okay so now let's
just go with it 90% of all businesses
fail are we freaking crazy for starting
a business I mean shouldn't we be afraid
to start a business
I mean let's just think about like in
your case at least you were young you
didn't you were young at the time and
even though at the time it seemed like
life was over your mom could have sat
behind you and went you know it you were
gonna get through it but this is very
real for people who are looking for
those second incomes in order to get by
and and right it could mean divorce it
can mean bankruptcy it can mean so many
things should people go for it like yeah
so I think I think a good chunk of that
90 percent failure rate is people who
started the wrong business it's people
who are just trying to make a second
income people who look up in Forbes
magazine and see the hundred hottest
companies to start right now and they go
for it yeah it's like I don't know
anything about being a social media
marker but it's one of the hardest
things to do so I like if you start a
business around something you're not
passionate about you're gonna fail like
period like what kept me through was the
passion I had for what I was doing and
that's like the worst day of my life I
still want to wake up the next day go
back and this is like I want to continue
to pound my head on this thing like
what's gonna make you do that it's only
because you're insanely like you would
do it if you weren't getting paid you
know like you just if you like the work
too many people are too attached to the
outcome like I need to make this amount
of money to pay my mortgage or whatever
but you don't like the work if you don't
like the work forget it you have to
enjoy the process the process is not
work it's fun that's what saves you that
the process doesn't make you come alive
then you're doing the wrong thing and so
most people in this sort of business
they don't think like that and they just
try to start a company and of course
like Suzy gets hard it's good you're
gonna stop like yeah I would because
you're normal because you're you're not
crazy in love with this I so agree with
you I tell moms all the time you don't
have time to start a hobby like if
you're gonna do this you have to be all
in I'm not saying don't be all in with
your kids but you have to be all in
mentally physically you've got to be
spiritually you got to be ready to go
because it's hard and you're gonna hit
those challenges and when you
those challenges you that vision is that
thing that keeps you on that path every
day that belief that you talk about all
the time of just you know mean we
obviously have to be observant and be
analyzing our business so we can make
pivots and shifts and do all of that but
don't you feel you have to be all in I
think there's two ways to look at it I
do think like you've got to be all-in
from an emotional point of view and that
you have to love absolutely what you're
doing and the longer you stay at
something that you don't love you're
just gonna continue to be mediocre right
and talent would get you so far but if
you look at you know and this isn't just
entrepreneur's anything like look at the
top person in any in any business in any
field in any endeavor they love the
process of what they're doing
we're like the person who's in charge of
an accounting company loves accounting
running in the counter helping the
person is just like mailing it in and
it's just doing the nine-to-five man you
know they love accounting they're living
for the weekends
they're just they're just gonna stay
there they're not gonna ever get
anywhere higher rather side to it like
people don't have to be all in I think I
think you have to be all in from an
emotional point of view like you have to
love what it is about like it it pains
you not to do it
like I love helping entrepreneurs I will
forget to go to the bathroom and forget
to and like I'm drinking a smoothie
right now but it's like I haven't eaten
since breakfast yeah well I have a clock
almost here you know and it's like yeah
I forget to take care of myself if my
wife doesn't matter to me instead of how
is lunch well you know so but like this
is the point like I'm all in emotionally
right like I love what I'm doing I into
my own detriment because I love it so
much and that's what you need to find
the all in that I don't believe it is
like you need to burn the boats you need
to go full time you need to quit your
job and like right away do it because
that happens a lot of people and then
they burn through their savings in three
months in the back doing where I think
it's okay to start part-time to do it
moonlighting dispense I agree
absolutely agree with that and for me
all-in doesn't mean all in ten hours a
day I'm 100% in agreement with you but
whatever you're carving out if it's two
hours a day you know like I work with a
lot of network marketers and they'll
only hit be able to put in two hours a
day well then like be all-in during that
two hours because you got to make those
two hours count right and you should
want to be putting in for even though
you're only doing two like you're up at
night thinking about it how you want to
grow it what else you want to do like I
dream about my youtube channel I dream
about the entrepreneurs in a discman
like we didn't got this call and like oh
I've got this idea for a me you know I
can wonder if she's like it's just I
love it I'm going to be in the shower
okay do you think they're what is the
biggest fear that maybe people don't
even realize that's a great question the
way that I would handle that is I think
most of the limiting beliefs that people
have are subconscious
I think most of the reasons that people
give for not doing something RBS they're
not necessarily in touch with it you're
saying yeah I think like so here's an
example for me I had I had a big fear
that I couldn't give value to people I
would fear like I really appreciate time
I value my time immensely and I value
the time of other people right let me
say you know Amy's gonna be on for this
time I make sure I'm there on time
always you know if I'm late I'm dead I'm
always there on time
so I value your time and I'm not worried
that uh I am and I am just dependent
depends on it I don't know I'm like a
habitual there's something I care like
insanely about and has to be done
perfectly and other things that like I
can let go so I would fear that that I
wouldn't give value because I really
appreciate and respect the other
person's time and so the positive side
it makes me over-deliver like try to
give a lot of value
chance to show up on time that's great
the con would be though that I would
find reasons not to go or worry too much
so as an example I remember one of the
first big presentation I did was in
Brunei and was gonna be like on live TV
and in front of the you know the royal
family and all this stuff and it was
like freaking me out and I said yes like
for four months in advance points in
advance and come like two weeks before
I'm secretly hoping that they're gonna
cancel on me like you know it's a you
busy or whatever we couldn't sell out
the conference like okay great okay and
and even for like and so that's that's
easy to understand some big thing even
for like meeting an entrepreneur who's
just getting started you have to talk
about their business
I would secretly fear that I wouldn't be
able to help this entrepreneur out we'd
good to give them value and I would
waste their time even though I know that
like that's never happened and right
it's always and it makes me feel good to
help them coming out of the bead and I'm
always on a super high but going in I
would always be super nervous and I
would secretly hoped that they would
cancel on me and so that's the deep
stuff but that's the stuff that you
don't notice subconsciously because
you'll find other reasons right like ah
you know I'm too busy to go to that or I
don't want to travel all the way there
or you know do you know with all of my
fans falling on me those are the reasons
right like so I'm booking a thing with
Tony Robbins likely in New York in July
where I'm gonna go to New York and
interview him on stuff I could easily
say you know what July is not a great
time or that's gonna cost too much to go
there I have too much happening here I
don't want to spend time away from my
wife or you know it's somewhat his
birthday I don't ever stay here like
there's a whole bunch of reasons that
every people would let me off the hook
for right like oh that's a totally legit
reason right like you want to spend time
with your wife that's an admirable thing
to do right but really it's just BS that
I'm telling myself because I'm afraid to
go and
do this action totally and isn't it
amazing that no matter how accomplished
you are no matter how much money you
make no matter how much success you've
achieved that fear still lives in you I
just got asked to do this pilot and I've
done I've done a lot of TV media and I
had the exact same thing and literally
this just happened yesterday and my
insides were like oh you know what I
have some referrals for you let me send
you a couple of people and he's like no
Amy we want you and I said all right so
we'll do a quick Skype interview
tomorrow but I had all of that going
through my head that let me come up with
a really good reason why I just can't
show up for the Skype meeting which is
ridiculous and of course I'm gonna show
up just like you're gonna show up right
what do you think that is like I think
you can fix it like I've pretty much
fixed it no seriously like it's just
it's just the awareness like yeah first
up is awareness because I didn't notice
this till I was I don't know how you
know maybe five years ago so how do I
now what matters it I'm like so say like
I'm 36 tomorrow's my birthday so 36
tomorrow thank you I maybe noticed it
was like when I was thirty let's say so
like I spent 30 years of my life just
making excuses yeah like not even
noticing and that's the problem with
most people right like and still with me
I'm sure there's other things that I'm
not even aware of and until you're aware
of it you can't solve it absolutely the
awareness is the first part but it's
almost never awareness in the moment
it's awareness after it's the Monday
Morning Quarterback it's the like I
shouldn't you know when I was talking to
Amy I should have said this what I
didn't like I really wish that I had you
know that I said this but you know what
you always question yourself afterwards
so you can catch it later like oh you
know what I shouldn't have been afraid
of that but you catch it afterwards the
next step is catching it in the moment
right like I'm feeling it now I'm aware
that I'm feeling it now and then it's
actually taking that fearful step right
like okay I feel the fear it's not the
fear goes away but I'm feeling that fear
and I'm gonna just go through it and do
it anyway yeah and the more that you do
that yeah the more you get used to doing
that the less
becomes 100% so then I'm a muscle so how
do you think then fear is always gonna
happen we're stepping outside of our
comfort zone fear comes up and what
you've really mastered is managing it
and I think that you know by being aware
of it and accepting it and then chatting
it out with fear and then making a new
decision but now you can do that in like
you know a minute how can you use fear
to make money so that's the interesting
one you know for me I'm not money given
I'm impact driven but they're related
right I want to have an impact if I have
an impact economic money money's that
money's comes from providing values the
more value can provide the more money
you're going to make so then it becomes
okay how can I use fear to provide value
to help somebody out it's a lot of
different ways to do it one I think is
you know overcoming your own fear so
like you shared your story about getting
on YouTube you went from like not having
anything it means that we're scared and
now like 200 videos in eight weeks or
something right like something crazy
that can motivate other people so by you
being vulnerable and sharing your fears
mm-hmm other people have the same fear
will see themselves in you and now that
you help you know you overcame it you're
helping them overcome it whether you
give them the specific steps to do it or
whether you just put it on their map
like you gave them the awareness that
they did something wrong right like not
pretending you're saying just by simply
announcing and admitting and sharing and
being vulnerable about fear
we give hope for others and inspiration
for them to move past theirs and that's
a business model right like more people
are gonna listen to your podcasts and
more people gonna check out your YouTube
videos and even though that's not like
it's done sir the intention you're not
sharing your story because you're trying
to cash in and make money you're trying
to help people and the more you help
people the more you will end up I mean
bless you through your own fears like me
being afraid to go to Brunei or me being
afraid to have that coffee meeting there
mean right like I'm closing down
opportunities for myself because I was
afraid so by breaking that and crashing
through the fear now I'm able to take
those meetings and going with more
confidence
to realize I can add value you know the
first time I had a brand meeting you
know talking with Microsoft and Xerox
and these companies are one of the
hiring me to help them I felt like what
does Microsoft need me for Microsoft is
like multi-billion dollar company you
know all these budgets how what value a
Microsoft and this is the same fear back
when I was in my software company I was
selling the guys three times my age you
had PhDs and all this experience but
they're gonna buy scientific software
from a 19 year old kid who doesn't
understand science or software and for
the longest time I didn't want to talk
to anybody on the phone it was all by
email and then I realized all they
really care about is if I can help them
and when I made that shift and I
realized they do they're willing to talk
to me if they see that I can help them
in their process help them make their
lab more efficient I sort of talk to the
Microsoft and ask them about their
strategy to help entrepreneurs and like
oh man you guys yeah I can help I cannot
because you took the focus off of the
fears there but you took the focus off
the fear and put it on okay maybe
they're crazy but they think I can
provide them value so let me put the
focus on them ask them questions and
suddenly you're in your space you're in
that place where you go oh I can give
value here I can give value there love
it well I know you don't have that much
more time can I want to ask you some fun
questions
those were fun I'm not saying those well
what's your what's your favorite quote
what's my favorite quote Evan
Carmichael's favorite quote right here
right now it was different quotes I
think back to Calvin Coolidge is one of
the US presidents that like basically
the US president nobody's heard of and
he said persistence alone is omnipotent
mm-hmm basically there's a whole thing
that goes into everybody saying it's not
about your talents not about your genius
no about your resources it's about just
being persistent and if you're
persistent it will work out it so
persistence alone is omnipotent Calvin
Coolidge I love it
well that's really what you did when you
started your company and we're eating
not fries yeah when you were not eating
french fries you just got back in the
game right keep moving I love that
what's your biggest aha moment biggest
aha moment I think I think the one that
kind of set the path for me was when I
was at my lowest days at my software
company recognizing that I did not have
to come up with every idea of myself and
that I could model success and what
turned the tide for making $300 a month
to now having a business and being
acquired in three years was I looked at
how guys like Bill Gates started
Microsoft like zero to one how did they
do that
and looked at those lessons and applied
it to my business and then adjusted
where before I tried to come with
everything myself I didn't recognize
that a lot of the path that or anything
built I just had to model it
and I've done that ever since like who's
already doing a great job here how can i
model the success and make it look for
me love it what what's your proudest
moment proudest moment it's interesting
I think the easiest want to say is like
the birth of my son or my wedding that's
a good one is but it feels like a
cop-out but it isn't isn't it I mean oh
my god my wife is watching she's gonna
be upset I mean isn't it like you sit
there and go I did this this is I well
your wife did but you contributed a
little show from mommy's right but I
mean I'm sorry that's my proudest moment
because at the end of the day what you
realize is nothing else it's not that
nothing else matters it's that
everything matters because of your child
your child to me makes things matter
more than they used to
she liked puppetry this rose-colored
like life and goodness on everything
it's like this right here is not just
water it's freakin awesome water
as of my daughter and because of your
kids and you know okay I love you I'm so
this was so much fun I don't I don't
ever want to end this but I do want
there were some things do any final
words I want to recap some things that
you said that really stuck with me but
you have any final thoughts or words to
our moms sure final thoughts I think
moms understand the the importance of
hard work
I think moms are one of the hardest
working you know group of people out
there like yeah you just you just
constantly working and having a kid
immediately forces you to step up your
game you thought you working hard before
now you realize how hard you're actually
working yeah it's pretty life-changing I
would say one make sure that you're
spending your time doing things that
you're passionate about in all areas of
life I mean we're talking about in the
business context but you know the people
that you're around should lift you up
you should be excited to go meet them
and hang out with them not not the other
people who kind of judge you and bring
you down the work that you do when you
do have time should be work that
fulfills you
work that you you know again the work
itself is something that you love and
always be searching for something Korea
that you can get into and not feel yeah
I've met a lot of Ceja moms and a lot of
them will feel like they don't know what
to do next
like their identity becomes only about
the child and they may lose their
identity and so like find yourself again
and do something that like do something
for you as well that makes you come
alive that you like can put some energy
into on a regular basis and then the
second point there is just create an
environment for greatness create an
environment that builds you up if you
want to do great things you need
greatness around you from the podcast
you listen to to the videos you watch
and the media you consume in the books
that you read have daily habits that set
you up to be more successful than
you are today and surround yourself with
people who see greater things for you
than you may see yourself and believe in
that vision I love that I love that I
love so many things that you said today
I need you to tell your mom that I'm
such a big fan that was my most favorite
thing that she said to you that I think
we have to now say to ourselves like you
said I take responsibility it's on you
it's your life you don't like it change
it love it keep it the same I mean at
the end of the day it's on you but that
belief thing it doesn't matter if it's
your mom
that said that to you if she doesn't say
that to you put yourself around people
who do say that to you and say it to
yourself like you can do anything that's
what she said you can do anything my
most exciting thing that you taught me
today that I'm gonna make sure that I'm
saying that I mean I believe that I
didn't to make sure I use those words
with my three-year-old daughter every
day and the takers if you want yeah
please yeah just up it just like a
little laughs kind of tip it there so my
son Hayden this is six years old now and
we've developed a routine where you know
if they come up from school or whatever
we're doing you know the first time I
see him it'll be I will say I'm Hayden
Carmichael and I can do and then he'll
say anything and yeah maybe it's cheese
volley or whatever so I like getting
them involved in it too so like they
believe it not just you telling them but
they're saying it to themselves
it's just they need that that's not
cheeseball
that's inspiration and give it to them
because they'll have so if we can if we
can create that for them young then they
get the foundation that you that you
were raised with and what a leg up you
know it is nice to be raised from a
family that is saying those things to
you and then the passion part you know
we can do anything if we're gonna spend
eight ten five to 12 hours a day on
something love it
freaking love it if not change it and we
actually can change it so I loved that
and then you know I had a couple of tips
on fear some you said today so I love
when when we're in sync the first thing
acknowledge it the sex thing and the
second thing is
it's a natural part of growing and
stepping outside of your comfort zone so
hey you have to see it there to accept
that it's there three build a
relationship with it talk to it talk to
your fear don't do it in public people
might think you're nuts but sit and have
a chitchat with fear because you got to
reconcile it you you ought to be able to
say hey love you thank you for
protecting me I appreciate it but I
don't need protection and then make a
powerful choice despite it you know I
always say choose to love fear love it
because you know what fear what it means
it means something awesome is about
ready to happen to you assuming that
we're not talking about rational
rational fear like fear because the cars
coming at you I'm talking about
irrational fear love it because
something you are on the cusp of
something awesome so look at it manage
it talk to it make a powerful choice
despite it Steve Jobs said I'm going to
read this quote great things in business
are never done by one person they're
done by a team of people and you said
that today too
and I think that what that reminds me of
is that I don't have to carry the burden
of fear alone if I've got a team and
people around me who are successful they
can really help me move through it so
that I can get to believing in myself
and then taking the actions that extend
into that which create success in all
areas of life so that's what I have to
say about today I love this this is then
one of my most favorite interviews this
is pitch me moms people if you have
business ideas or you're an expert that
wants to to help our community please
tune in to pitch me mom's subscribe get
involved really excited about Evan
Carmichael thank you so much for being
here
and thanks for having me it's been
awesome huh totally awesome so let's
answer more questions you have questions
that came in or what should we do
yeah I mean I haven't been keeping track
of the chat but it's it's on fire
Zeno's asking or more common awesome Amy
that could be your nickname if it isn't
already I would like it thank you
no one's ever said that actually I think
I should have a shirt it says awesome
Amy Amy
it may be arrogant but it's certainly
confident let's just don't don't don't
be afraid though don't don't call it
there again right awesome Amy it's not
going to arrogant Amy how do you step
out of your comfort zone that is a great
question um I do things I'm afraid of
very simply I don't like to get I get a
little bored when I'm not stepping out
of my comfort zone so it's a bit
inherent in me however I like to push
the boundaries so I think about where
I'm at I think about where I'd like to
go
typically wherever I'd like to go is
usually scary and so I have that moment
of are you crazy and then I go okay
great how am I going to get there and
then I create the action steps and I
take action one and as soon as I've
taken action one I'm stepping outside of
my comfort zone yeah I think I'm going
to cover a lot of different versions of
this already on the show I like to
challenge and follow my curiosity hmm I
like to do things that I think it's not
cheap fares to come with ideas we want
to test them out and I'm not the kind of
guy who has like in five years I'm gonna
do this like I just start like as soon
as a good idea
just start yeah just like a must and
just find a small way to start it
doesn't doesn't have to be this huge
step but oh I need tons of funding or I
need the right partner or I need XYZ to
happen just find a small way and start
until many people leave you know with
the Whitsitt coat too many people die
with their song still in them yeah too
many people just have the bucket lists
of things that they never wanted they
want to do what they never get done I'm
gonna be doing my youtube channel about
what the
my birthday and it said cross something
off your bucket list that's that's
that's what I want you to get me for my
birthday do something for you that's
incredible I love that you're saying
that I think we people get paralyzed
with fear and then they they stop even
dreaming and what's so exciting is that
once you can build this relationship
with fear and it's allowed to hang out
and you don't see it as the as this
horrific kind of you know devilish thing
that's supposed to prevent you from
acting in life and you can just be one
with it like what was that movie A
Beautiful Mind right what's his name I
can't remember that out made huge actor
and a beautiful mind yes Russell Crowe
and he started t just started talking
with his personalities and then he
became one with them and he could
function with them and when you do what
you just said you have an idea you just
go for it because that paralysis isn't
stopping that it's not you're not
paralyzed you're just going okay let's
go yeah I think the biggest thing has
helped me is Jeff Bezos is from
amazon.com his regret minimization
framework which is basically look at
your life when you're 90 back on your
this moment right now will you regret
not doing it yeah and is the fear like a
real fear is the fear just something you
need to break through like for me I'm
afraid of heights somebody wants me to
go bungee jump with them or not bungee
jumping now when you just from a plane
yeah they're called skydive I'm with you
right I did that I like I'm afraid of
heights I have no interest in fixing it
like I do not want to confront that fear
and I'm cool with it yeah it's like I
don't feel like it holds me back in life
great so I'm good like I don't even
think I know because it's a real fear
but I you know whatever it doesn't hold
me back we're other ones like needing
the provide value or I'm sure there's a
whole bunch of other ones that I just
subconsciously do and tell myself those
are the ones needs fixing
so like looking back in my life when I'm
90 years old
I didn't jump from that plane I'm good
with that I don't need to change that
okay not taking that
business opportunity instead of going
through the safe job that that was scary
to me so yeah make the go do it
sensation I is asking I want to switch
from my study because I don't like this
one but I'm afraid me yeah you go she
wants to switch her studies like
whatever her arrogance is in school
right but she's afraid to write she
doesn't like it she's doing now or he I
don't know since station I yeah you know
what I always like to ask myself fear
this is why having a conversation with
fear is so important because you're in
fear it's some Bilt's thing you've
practiced and so you're in it and oh my
gosh it's gonna be this life-altering
threatening mo you know you got to talk
you got to talk it out so the question
is what's the what's the worst-case
scenario if you change your focus what
could happen what could happen if you
change what you're from where you're
studying you know what you're studying
now to what you want to study what's the
worst thing that could happen you're in
school longer maybe your mom will be mad
cuz you don't want to be a doctor you
know I always think of it like this
let's say it's something dramatic like
that because that's a very real
conversation for people I always say and
maybe this is harsh stay in your own
lane right at the end of the day if you
don't want to be a doctor your mom or
anybody else in your life they don't
have to live your life you do you have
to show up for it you get the
consequences of it you get the good or
bad it's all it's all you get it all so
ask yourself that question because it
opens up a can of other questions a lot
of worms and usually you can end up
reconciling does that make sense yeah
you know the way I'm thinking about is
through an analogy gee do you watch any
sports me yeah I watch it sport I love
to watch gymnastics and I love to watch
swimming okay I know nothing about
either then well let's go swimming
I just really no I just a touchdown I
know it's okay it's all good you see
like I believe the stuff like I asked
you who's the greatest swimmer of all
time like Michael Phelps or you know now
that I know so we'll go with him okay
yeah I believe the greatest swimmer of
all time is not Michael Phelps I believe
the grid the greatest swimmer of all
time never got in the pool
yeah and never realize their potential
to be the greatest swimmer of all time
and so your responsibility is to find a
thing that you could be the greatest of
all time at and too many people don't
give themselves the option yeah you get
locked on one path and then you stay on
that path for the rest of your life and
every day just becomes more and more
soul-sucking you know like I went to I
want to be an accountant because my dad
was an accountant and I'm good with
numbers and they're like every day
becomes more and more of a grind until
the point where you just like give up on
life where it's like this is now your
life
and you hate it and that's 95% of
America where I think you need to go out
and explore and find the things that you
could be you know better than Michael
Phelps Act yeah because the best swimmer
in the world like right now that guy is
like a manager at Starbucks or he's a
tax lawyer or something that he's not
liking where he could have been the best
swimmer in the world is feeling this
study's more like immediately as soon as
you lose the passion for something move
on immediately and don't let the success
that you've had in the past being anchor
for you to prevent you from going
forward and having your success in the
future it's it's a serious life-changing
moment when you really think about it
right I just have to say this it is a
life-changing moment
that I I don't it's a I don't know her
name it's a life-changing moment because
you have an opportunity right now still
in
school to define the trajectory of your
life is it gonna be based on just I'm
just gonna suck it up and do something I
don't care about and and that's what I'm
gonna practice in life or right now when
I'm young and I have my whole life in
front of me am I gonna make that that
choice right now that I choose me I
choose me I choose what I believe in I
choose what I want and if you make that
choice today you'll build that strength
that will make it easier for you to
continue to make those choices in your
life
because you will have you will have done
it I like it
battle sheep is riding in the say asking
how to get over camera shyness has a
webcam knows how to use it but it's too
shy to go on camera is a gamer so I
guess with a lot of the gamers like they
stream their face as their gaming too
but yeah battle sheep is to camera
battle sheep there's one way that you do
it you do it that's it there is no magic
pill you put the camera on and you
choose that it is okay if I make a toad
are we allowed to swear on this podcast
it's it's a it's a family show oh sorry
you gotta be willing to make a fool out
of yourself you got to be willing to
make a fool out of yourself
it's okay worst-case scenario is is you
know what it wasn't so great okay
the only way you get good at anything is
through practice that's it that's how
you get good when you look at I when I
watched Oh Evan you're still gonna
relate with me on this watching my
little child because it's so fresh right
learn how to walk and it's so funny
because if she was like getting up and
falling and getting up I'm fine
I can pretty much bet you that there was
never a time in her little life where
she said you know I just haven't been
able to get up the last six times so I'm
just not gonna get up now I'm just done
I'm not gonna walk I mean we all walk so
if you mean that our legs are working we
all walk so you just they're just doing
the differences they don't have a fear
of failing and they don't have a fear of
looking bad and they don't have a fear
of
being vulnerable and they don't have all
those fears so what I have to say is is
just start shooting them and be willing
to make a fool out of yourself and say
it's gonna be okay because I promise you
by the 10th 50th five hundredth video
that you do you're gonna go I'm pretty
good this is not that big of a deal
it took me seven hundred something
videos until I wasn't embarrassed by
myself embarrassed I couldn't watch
anything seven hundred videos it's crazy
right that's all I felt I felt better
sooner than that
but that is nothing I learned like I
just through persistence I think what
will probably help is like you're
comparing your start to somebody else's
middle yeah you look at other gamers or
you're looking at Amy's channel or
whatever and you see the people who look
good at what they're doing like well I
can't do that well cuz you're at the
start go back and watch the go back
watch my first video watch mine it's
still up it sucks you know I'm trying to
memorize it's super boring yeah you can
see the journey for the gamers that you
look up to go back and watch their first
video chances are they sucked right so
like compare your start to somebody else
to start and for me more importance
compared yourself to who you were
yesterday and are you growing if you're
better than you were yesterday then
you're making progress and you'll
eventually catch up yeah but comparing
yourself to somebody else's middle
you're going to lose every time
absolutely I couldn't agree more a bunch
of comments about your name we had
awesome
Amy shine is gonna go with amazing Amy
oh nice the thin network wants to go
with astonishing Amy and Michael wants
to go with action Amy so we have awesome
amazing astonishing sorry Z astonishing
Amy not just me in action Amy so you can
you get a lot of t-shirts to come out
you got lots of slogan anytime you
slogan help you can come back on again
love it brainstorm it up yeah thank you
everyone that is that's amazing thank
you know what amazing so it might be
amazing Amy I like it I just Applebaum
well you can play with the bomb - come
on guys Wow
the nightmare growing up but we won't go
there something positive the bomb of
value bomb you know right you get a
little explosion in your life knowledge
bomb you know dropping bombs of wisdom
oh those like I like it nice we need to
riff I like it cool well we are like way
past time Amy for joining us dropping
some knowledge bombs thank you guys for
watching Amy for people to find out more
about you I linked up your website in
the description but anything else so
just any Apple Baum combo anything else
Amy Applebaum comm is where it's the hub
it's the hub for everything I have
another site I don't know if you know
this but I have created over a hundred
meditation albums and apps that I
launched and I'm very proud to say have
hit bestseller status on iTunes and
things like that if you want to go to
that separate website you could go to
Amy Applebaum meditation calm but you
can find it through Amy Applebaum calm
and please for the women and any men who
are experts who have something to say to
moms talk to me about the pitch my mom's
podcasts we've only done we just
launched this and I think we're on our
tenth or eleventh episode so we're
having fun you got a pitch Amy to be on
the pitch me mom's show that's right
when is when is this ever so gonna go on
this one that we're doing and probably
go live next week cool all right
well Amy again thank you super fun and
thank you guys who work and have a great
weekend
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon thank you thank you really fun